mark talk us through what we know so far
sure we know the Apple had planned to
release a new version of the Apple watch
this fall that includes cellular
connectivity but that means people would
be able to take their Apple watches and
leave their iPhone behind they'd be able
to get email text messages make some
wireless phone calls through the main
iPhone phone number but that plan was
hit by engineering roadblocks earlier
this year Apple and carriers around the
world determined that the battery life
took too much of a substantial hit due
to the high power of these cellular
chips available this year so market the
way you described it it sounds as though
if there were significant advances to be
made in battery technology in the near
future that could resolve these problems
absolutely both battery technology and
the technology powering the cellular
chips if they're able to make the chips
a little bit smaller in actual physical
size they can cram in a little bit of a
bigger battery but also if they make the
chips more power efficient then battery
life is not so much an issue
what about discussions with network
carriers because as app Eric was
mentioning this would be a cellular in
an independent watch that's independent
from the cell phone itself and you could
get a reception on it on its own what
kind of discussions have there been
between Apple and say 18t and Verizon
Apple had been discussing this cellular
Apple watch with carriers but since
earlier this year the discussions hit
sort of roadblocks toward the middle of
the year about these battery life
concerns Apple told carrier partners
around April May June that it would not
be able to ship such a model with
cellular until even on a very aggressive
timeline past the Christmas holiday
season at the earliest so the decision
was made to not announce it this year
even though they were planning they're
still planning to release an Apple watch
too without that functionality this fall
mark I do wonder whether there's ever
going to be a Eureka moment for the
Apple watch which takes it from being
kind of a niche product to something
that is truly mass-market and everybody
gets excited about this would appear to
have the potential to do that if it ever
happens have you seen any estimates any
ideas
how big the Apple watch might be in
terms of units shipped if it could do
these things you know even if Apple
grabs a small proportion but a single
percentage point at least or five
percent of iPhone sales that's still a
substantial amount so if they still say
sell 50 million iPhones and a quarter
and on top of that they sell 5 million
watches in that same quarter that's
pretty good and I think like you said
the cellular data would spur sales
because a lot of people are looking to
be able to take the watch drop the phone
replace it and not have to worry about
it
but just because the cellular is not
working out for this year that doesn't
mean there's not going to be
improvements towards independence
according to the people we spoke with
Apple still planning to integrate a GPS
chip inside the new version which will
allow people to run and walk and get
better tracking for the health
applications